olivier verrouillé créateur et animateur
du site les crises
bonsoir olivier veyrier merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france
tout d'abord il ya une réaction à ces
mesures prises depuis hier fermeture des
écoles réduction à 100 le nombre de
personnes autorisées à se rassembler
vous pensez que les mesures sont bonnes
non les mesures sont pas bonnes elles
sont dramatiquement insuffisante
il suffit de comparer tout ce que font
les principaux pays touchés
assez assez peu surprenant puisque la
france fait vraiment figure d'un des
pires élèves de la planète si c'est le
pire dans la gestion de cette crise
ce qui fait que la crise est terminée en
chine et que les maintenant localisé en
france espagne italie suisse
c'est ce que dit le ms aujourd'hui
l'europe serait l'épicentre et vient
effectivement de cette pandémie
vous êtes d'accord avec donald trump
quand il dit que l'europe est
responsable finalement de cette
propagation notamment aux états unis
en tout cas laurent peille énorme part
de responsabilité déjà dans le non
traitement de la protection de ses
propres citoyens
évidemment quand vous laisser partir une
épidémie elles dégénèrent sur toute la
planète les etats-unis ont aussi une
très grosse part de responsabilité je
vous rappelle qu'ils ont testé à peu
près de personnes puisqu'il fallait
payer pour se faire tester jusqu'à il ya
trois quatre jours alors il ya 79 morts
annoncées ce soir par par olivier
ferrand 3661 cas de contamination ses
800 de plus qui hier les chiffres sont
déjà importants vous pensez que ce ne
sont pas les bons chiffres
si c'est les bons chiffres en termes de
décès en termes de contamination c'est
en tout cas le chiffre des personnes que
l'état français a décidé de tester mais
il ya un très gros problème puisque
comment marche une épidémie une épidémie
c'est vous êtes qu'important puis vous
êtes contaminé puis vous incubés virus
pendant à peu près cinq jours puis vous
un jour vous commencez à voir des
symptômes dans un certain nombre de cas
il vous faut aller hôpital au bout de
trois quatre jours et puis au bout de 5
vous avez peu près testé positif
donc je voyais qu'il ya un grand délai
entre le moment où on est contaminé le
moment où vous êtes tester donc quand on
a un type de test c'est en fait les
tests qui correspondent aux malades d'il
ya une dizaine de jours mais simplement
l'expansion de la maladie est
exponentielle donc ça sous-estiment
gravement les le nombre réel de
personnes qui ont aujourd'hui le virus
mais dont la plupart n'ont pas encore de
symptômes ils vont les développer dans
les jours qui viennent
on entend beaucoup de témoignages de
personnes qui ont quelques symptômes a
priori qui ont appelé le 15 et on leur
dit restez chez vous ils ne sont pas
systématiquement des pistes et non plus
oui oui on peut plus le faire en fait
parce que l'épidémie est partie hors de
contrôle
enfin il faut être sérieux vers l'eau et
metz a déclaré le 30 janvier cette
épidémie comme une une maladie qui est
représenté une urgence de santé publique
mondiale la chine a immédiatement prises
les mesures elle a confiné sa population
le 22 janvier au moment où la chine
confirme sa population elle n'a même pas
300 cas chez nous là il y en a trois
mille six cent et ils sont très
largement sous-estimé parce que le
gouvernement n'arrive plus à faire les
tests comme il devrait le faire donc si
on les faisait bien il aurait déjà à
tout le moins dix vingt mille ha sont
des tests aujourd'hui des personnes qui
ont le virus beaucoup plus donc on est
complètement dépassé par la situation
puisque gouvernement n'a pas pris la
mesure de l'épidémie et elle est
totalement incontrôlable en trois
semaines on a perdu la guerre contre la
propagation du coroner virus la chine
l'a gagnée quand la chine l'a gagnée on
a tous ces images d'une chine qui
confine la population d'une région
entière qui à la tête de la france qui a
désinfecté les rues et qui au final
arrive à maintenir l'épidémie et le l'a
quasiment fini là bas pour le moment
quatre-vingt mille cas 3000 morts je
répète ils ont agi à 300k donc on voit
très bien l'énorme retard qu'on a qu'on
a là dedans quand ils ont fait ça nos
experts chez nous qui sont pas des
experts
ces experts sont l'évidence en chine et
porn europe sont des mandarins et on
s'est foutu de la gueule des chinois en
disant on va regarder tout ce ramdam
qu'ils ont fait au total il ya que 3000
morts c'est pas grand chose c'est même
pas une grippe
ben évidemment que vous prenez les
bonnes mesures vous arrêter l'épidémie
il ya plus de morts mais quand on en
déduit qu'il faut rien faire mal il se
passe ce qui se passe chez nous dans
notre monde une catastrophe sanitaire
majeure et on voit quand on est toujours
très très loin de faire ce qui est ce
qui est nécessaire
on voit très bien que vous
même le président macron mais absolument
pas à ces actes en action avec ses
paroles il a dit fort justement hier
c'est la pire crise depuis il a donné
dès 1918 c'est une urgence sanitaire
on voit qu enfin castanet amené à dire
qu'on peut encore aller manifester même
si c'est pas bien mais ces gens sont
vraiment dramatiquement incompétent et
on a des des résultats qui aujourd'hui
sont extrêmement inquiétant je viens de
publier sur twitter sur mon compte aux
berruyers les derniers chiffres de
l'italie sur les personnes contaminées
dont 1000 morts en italie déjà passé le
tiers des morts de la chine
ils sont très loin d'avoir commencé à
m'excuser l'épidémie il ya un taux de
mortalité des personnes testées de 10 %
des plus de 60 ans dont 17 % des plus de
80 ans
donc on voit très bien c'est une maladie
qui va très peu affecté les moins de 50
60 ans mais qui est dramatique pour les
vieux donc il faut vraiment agir pour
protéger la population en voit très bien
que certains pays ont fait et on va
tomber
certains pays n'ont pas fait donc on
s'est foutu de la gueule des chinois les
italiens n'ont pas fait au début il a
comme nous ils épidémie est partie
complètement avril ont une semaine
d'avant sur nous donc est tout à fait
possible que ce qui se passe en italie
ce soit en une semaine chez nous et que
fait le gouvernement il n'agit toujours
pas versé le dernier pays à page il faut
savoir que depuis aujourd'hui est
interdit d dans la rue en iran et l'iran
à maîtriser la maladie c'est pas fini
mais enfin on voit très bien
l'augmentation se fait linéairement et
n'ont plus qu'à exponentiellement près
que jamais vers l'absolu que devrait
faire la france selon vous moi j'ai un
message très clair pour emmanuel macron
il faut prendre l'art est vain c'est peu
ses responsabilités on attend vraiment
un homme détail c'est parce qu'on a eue
hier du tout le petit théâtre pendant
une demi heure c'était bien on attendait
des mesures fortes elles ne sont
toujours pas là
ce que doit faire emmanuel macron c'est
déjà se séparer de tous les
scientifiques et qui depuis deux mois
lui dise que ça restera en chine que
c'est pas grave et nous contacter ne
parler que ceux qui ont pris la mesure
des événements parce qu'il y en a dans
nos balances sans arrêt de les
scientifiques disent que ya pas d les
scientifiques comme y'a pas de les
médias des scientifiques y en a qui skie
en rigole depuis trois mois il y en a
qui sont inquiets depuis trois mois ceux
qui rigolent ils faut qu'ils restent
chez eux en confinement d'ailleurs et
puis les autres il faut absolument qu'on
les écoute ce que doit faire un manuel
macro j'appelle vraiment bien c'est
dramatique matière les municipales dans
une épée
me meilleurs que nous sur la planète
pour le faire ça qu'il faut annuler les
municipales au plus vite
donc j'attends qu'emmanuel macron
déclenché l'article 16 demain et l'état
d'urgence il faut absolument empêcher
les municipales ça va être dramatique
on arrête de rigoler redisons c'est la
même chose que faire des courses c'est
pas vrai de toutes façons les plus de 70
ans
il faut absolument qu'ils évitent de
faire des courses et c'est le message
qu'il faut faire passer et il faut
absolument qu'ils n'aient pas de contact
avec le virus de façon à couvrir un
minimum de risque évidemment quand on va
voter on prend un énorme risque sur sa
santé donc il nous faut pas le faire il
faut organiser des réseaux de solidarité
des plus jeunes à des moins de 50 ans
aider les plus de 70 à 80 ans il faut
alors leur faire leurs courses
il faut absolument leur donner les
courses sans trop leur parler il faut
absolument qu'il s'isole qui se met en
quarantaine volontaire pour ne pas subir
les taux de mortalité dantesque
aujourd'hui sont provisoires ils seront
peut-être un peu plus faible à la fin on
voit très bien que des taux de mortalité
aujourd'hui en italie de 10% des
personnes testées positives même si les
cas un peu graves sont dramatiques donc
il faut absolument qu emmanuel macron
prenne ses responsabilités près de
l'article 16 et arrête de raconter et
d'avoir aujourd'hui darmanin qui va
plastronner pourtant les listes à
tourcoing dimanche mais enfin c'est
stupéfiant il n'a pas remporté les
municipales parce qu'on apprend qu'il
voulait le faire
on peut saluer emmanuel mâcon qui avait
quand même un peu décidé d'agir on
apprend que larcher et fab us ont refusé
de d'accompagner le président macro
enfin demandé aux types du sang
contaminé de prendre des mesures de
santé publique nationale mais il faut
quand même être cinglé donc maintenant
il faut écouter les experts il faut agir
et agir vite parce que vraiment les
vieux sont en danger
et voilà on peut pas laisser cette
situation se détériorer merci beaucoup
olivier veyrier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france